so my view is for any political party
you have to start with your base you're
caught vote and then built outwards and
for labour look at the history of the
Labour Party its core values
working-class people that's what it was
set up to represent in those you know
some of those constituencies we listed
that the now gone sorely that's where
you start as a Labour Party now labour
will only succeed electorally in my view
and has historically only succeeded
electorally when it's been able to
maintain the trust of its core vote at
the same time as appealing to a
sufficient layer of if you like more
middle class more liberal less tribal
voters and I'm certainly not somebody
who says the path to victory in the
future for the Labour Party is just to
appeal exclusively to the old industrial
working class that you know we've got to
do is appeal to the people in the dom
valleys and the bowls overs and that's
it we're back on the path to victory
actually you know i think it's good we
can win other places like cancer
brilliant kensington and places like
that i think the problem has been
certainly more recently as is that we
have won some of those other places at
the expense of if you like the
traditional working-class areas and
that's because as a party we have become
so obsessed with one part of that
equation which is the the sort of
middle-class liberal part of the
equation whilst almost ignoring the the
sort of more traditional working-class
part of the equation and i think that
that a big reason for that is because
the party itself the composition of the
party the demographic of the party has
changed so significantly over the recent
years i've been in the party for twenty
five years and actually in my time the
party has changed hugely i mean there
was a time where you know you go to
labour party conferences for example and
there would be
you know strong working-class voices
they're people who had come up through
the trade union movement manual workers
blue-collar workers who were now trade
unionists and ordinary grassroots
members of constituency labor parties
going to Labour Party conference over
the years those voices have become fewer
and fewer and the more dominant voices
have become those sort of middle-class
woke sort of liberal cosmopolitan voices
to the degree now where you go to Labour
Party conferences and you just realized
that it really isn't a reflection of the
country at large 77 percent of the party
come from the sort of abc1 middle class
social grade the party has got hardly
any roots now in many of those
constituencies those sort of
working-class constituencies so unless
the party can can find a way of shifting
the the emphasis if you like from the
sort of middle-class liberal globalist
cosmopolitan city based element of it
back to you know the traditional
working-class areas and trying to build
a coalition you know as I say build from
your base and work out rather than you
know look to that that sort of a new
constituency and hope that the
working-class stays with you which it
didn't then unless the Labour Party can
can do that then I think frankly it
could be it could be out of power for at
least ten years I think there's a
question over the future of the Labour
Party is a party of government a sort I
think there's a danger it becomes a
permanent protest movement in the signs
since the election are not good you know
if you look at some of the frontrunners
for the Labour leadership I think
they're you know they've got nothing
against them personally but I think
they're everything that's wrong with the
Labour Party to a certain degree
you know I've pitched it as we've become
all Hampstead and not enough Hartlepool
over recent years and I think if you
look at people like kiost Alma and Emily
Thornbury and Clyde Lewis those people
are not going to win back some of those
constituencies that we need to win but
what about Rebecca long bailing because
she thought that Corbin's leadership was
ten out of ten yeah she's the one more
heave candidate that's the
and again nothing personal I'm sure
she's I'm sure she's a very decent
principled woman but the the idea that
you know we just we just didn't try hard
enough
and we didn't sort of push hard enough
and and these people really are on board
with what we're arguing we just need you
know one more heave we just need to
redouble our efforts I think is is
delusional
[Music]